and then let's have a go at it so
integral of what was it um
bracket through X
X Plus by Rex
with respect to X I really hope yeah
okay fantastic so
um now before I help you out with this
question which I promise I will what was
the first instinct because you have some
working there and I just wanted to draw
on it because it's on the right track
but I want to help you know why you're
not getting an answer out of it so what
did you try and do
it was something with this denominator
right yeah yeah okay so you had this uh
we called it a this is a binomial right
and it's a binomial
expansion right because we're going to
square in a minute and then when you you
said brought it up what do you mean by
that can you expand that a little bit
and negative
good so actually you did two things at
the same time so number one you said hey
I know that that is actually x to the
power of a half write an index form
right and in addition to that it's on
the denominator so if I write it on the
numerator that's why it becomes a
negative index yes okay and then there's
a DX there now
I'm going to suggest this is actually a
good thing to do we are just not
finished yet but I'm going to ask you
like what made you think that this would
be better than this
yeah it's like I don't know I saw it
done once like an example did it okay
I'm gonna suggest to you why
um we're integrating integrating is the
thing that we learn as sort of at least
this is how we start learning about it
it's the reverse of differentiation
right this kind of undyes what
differentiation does have you done areas
yet no so you're going to learn soon
that actually integration is more than
just the reverse of differentiation but
for now it's just undoing it right now
if I gave you this thing and I said can
you differentiate this please would you
be able to do it forget about
integrating I just gave you this thing
and told you to differentiate do you
think you could
I'm going to suggest to you even if
nothing is like immediately jumping to
mind even though it's going to be a bit
of a pain you can you can differentiate
this thing right I'll show you how if
you took this
uh what kind of a function is this it's
something divided by another so we have
a rule for that right starts with a Q
what's it called question rule very good
so you would say I'll call the numerator
something I'll call the denominator
something else and then do you remember
what the actual quotient rule is it
starts with a
yeah UV Dash
b u Dash
over
V squared very good okay it is so very
close you're almost exactly there the
only thing that's different is it's
actually backwards so they're in reverse
order but that's okay you get the
general idea right now here's the thing
for differentiating we've got a quotient
rule
for integrating there is no question
room so you look at it and you're like
this is gross and so whenever you get
presented with a quotient when you're
integrating your instinct is correct
that you like at all costs get rid of
the quotient there's a small number of
questions where you can deal with a
quotient but
um they're not that common and so we're
just gonna not worry about it for now
okay so what I do is I'm going to take
this but I'm going to suggest that like
well you're still kind of stuck aren't
you
um when you look at this it certainly
doesn't match any formula you've seen
before and so what are we going to do
with this to to deal with it
can I ask you if it was just this just
this part
could you deal with that
could you just integrate x to the power
of negative a half
I think we could right what would you
what would you do can you walk me
through it
um
yeah very good so this is X to the power
of some number it's a gross number but
actually that's fine um it can be any
number you like it can be negative it
can be a fraction it could be a square
root it could be like some ridiculous
number like I didn't know what that
means right but everything you just said
would work you would say it again you
would add one to the power
and then divide by whatever that was
right uh sorry these are two different
questions you'd increase the power by
one and then you divide by whatever that
power is I have no idea what that means
but that process is actually something
you can do to any number so that's fine
I could deal with this I just have to
deal with all of this stuff over here
now even though it looks terrible I
promise you can deal with it right let
me try and give you a version of this
that's just a little bit simpler and
then you tell me what you'd do with it
again I'm going to do it over here on
the right hand side suppose you had not
that but
X plus b
squared
what would you do with that
if remember we're integrating right how
would you integrate this
hmm
so I can do something very similar to
this right that'll be fine
um however it doesn't always work right
this rule that you're telling me about
right if I've got extra things in here
like say a cubed
I actually can't do this have you
encountered questions like this yet
where there's something weird and awful
in there right and that's kind of what
we have to deal with here okay so here's
how we avoid this problem right just
don't have something with brackets I've
got something with brackets here and
it's squared but I can actually just
multiply this out I can just treat this
like any old expansion right so let me
give me give us some more space here
and let's see if we can just do it step
by step okay so integrate what I've got
here is the square root of x plus b
and squaring just means do it again
square root of x
plus b okay
now uh you wrote this x to the power of
negative half over here I'll just leave
him hanging out there we'll come back to
him later on
integrate now have a look at this right
if you got given any expansion like
forget about calculus for a minute it's
just some stuff some algebraic terms
multiplied by other ones right how would
you expand something like this what
would you do
yeah how would you do that it won't be
the first two things that you would
there's there's multiplication happening
here right so what would be the first
two things that you would multiply one
by the other
um
yeah fantastic so you would do the the
first ones right
um I often the way I did it in my brain
is I I do this one and I'd do it twice
right and then I've got another color
here
I do the second one and I'd also do that
one
twice okay so let's just go through this
one step at a time so I've still got
some brackets here but root x times root
X what's that
it's just X cool
root x times B it's like oh well B is
just a it's just a constant isn't it so
normally I would write constants out the
front like so
what I do next
I've done the orange ones right I'm up
to now the the green ones so I've got B
times root X so that seems familiar
and then can you tell me what's the last
term B squared very good
now this even though it's longer it's
much easier to deal with right because I
can just go term by turn and integrate
one thing at a time right except there
is this thing that's just hanging out
here right so let's just put that there
now at this point here I've got a few
different things I could simplify does
anyone have any suggestions what I
should simplify first
yeah what about it
um yeah we've got a name for that we
call it collecting like terms because
they're both a square root of x term so
what have I got here is integral of
X Plus
yeah I've got two of them
B squared
and Co at this point you have collected
all the like terms you can but what I
can do with this thing in here is the
thing that was your instinct in the
first place you know how you put this
square root you put into index form
right that's because square roots are
gross in in calculus terms but indices
are easy even when there are weird
indices like square roots or Pi or
things like that so help me out here
I've got
an X regular odd X that's fine but then
what's this going to be
x to the half so I've got 2 b x to the
half
plus b squared
okay it's kind of funny because we're
like I'm supposed to be integrating I
haven't done any integrating yet we are
one step away
this multiplied by everything inside
yeah so I'm going to need to do this one
at a time is that okay so when I do it
for the first term x times x to the
negative a half what do you remember
about your index laws there's really a
one hiding there
yeah I'm going to add those indices
right so one
Plus
negative a half is just
a half because the same as subtraction
so x to the half okay watch out for this
one this is um don't worry about the
constant coefficient x to the half
times x to the negative half what
happens in the disease
yeah they cancel out by the way of
course they cancel out because this used
to be a root X and this used to be a
divide by root X so that's why they just
cancel each other so that leaves you
with 2B
and then this is just a constant So it's
b squared times well there's no other X
terms so I'll just
write that as it is
hooray all of that is going to be
integrated